foreign
today we'll take you through a hands of
lab demo of how you can detect hate
speech using machine learning
before we start I hope the screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues to let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them
I'm repeating again before we start I
hope the screen is clearly visible and
the audio is fine if yes just type in
yes if there are any issues do let us
know in the chat section so that we can
resolve them
let's wait for some more minutes to let
other people join
until then let me tell you guys that we
have regular updates on multiple
Technologies
if you are a tech geek or a continuous
hunt for the latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
learn I'm repeating again let me tell
you guys that we have regular updates on
multiple Technologies
if you are a techie in a continuous hunt
for the latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
learn
I think we can get started
so in today's session we will go through
what hate speeches
after that a hands of live demo of how
to detect hate speech using machine
learning we will perform different
function and different python libraries
before we move on to the programming
part let's discuss hate speech and
proceed further for the same
so what is head speech any speech that
dispersed a group of people because of
their race religion nationality national
origin sexual orientation or gender
identity is considered as hate speech
hate speech is frequently used to
promote pegoty and hatred additionally
it can be applied to threaten and
intimate others
people may experience loneliness anxiety
and fear as a result
hate crimes may also result from it
additionally hate speech can harm
between various racial and ethnic groups
it is crucial to identify hate speech
using since doing so can assist in
stopping these negative impacts the
Learners if you want to upskill your AI
and machine learning skills so give
yourself a chance to Simply learn
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with
the completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course detail from the
description box below
so here is one question for you guys I
will give you exactly one minute for
this you can comment or you can give
your answer in the chat section so I can
see with the answers given by you are
right.raw I'm repeating again here is
one question for you I will give you
exactly one minute for this
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I I can
see if your answers given by your right
order
so the question is
all keywords in Python are capitalized
lower case
uppercase and none
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
so I am starting the timer of one minute
okay
the time start now to let me know your
answers please
just type your answer in the comment
section or in the chat section
all python keywords are in
capitalize lowercase uppercase none
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
30 seconds remaining
all keywords in Python are capitalized
lowercase uppercase or none
seconds small
keywords in Python are capitalized
lowercase uppercase and none
let us know your answer in the comment
section below please
five seconds more
after the allotted time has passed Those
Who provided the correct response will
receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one
so now let's move to our programming
part
first we will open command prompt to
write a command to open Jupiter notebook
so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
Center
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you have to go new
python
this is the how the Jupiter kernel look
likes
so here
we will import some major libraries or
python which will help in analyzing the
data so here I will write import
ant as
PD
import
numpy
as and B
then from
sqln
the
action
or text
counter vectorizer
okay
then one more strum
model selection
okay
test underscore split
and prom
iscalon
pottery
import
ant
okay
okay counter vectorizer
account vectorizer it is
so number is a python Library used for
working with array it also has a
function for working with the domain of
linear algebra and matrices
it is an open source project and you can
use it freely numpy stand for numerical
python
and pandas pandas is a software Library
written for the Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis in particular it offers data
structure and operation for manipulating
numerical tables and Time series
this count vectorizer a fantastic
utility offered by the python
scikit-learn modulus count vectorizer
it is used to convert a given text into
a vector base on the number of times
like count that each word appears across
the full text
train test split
so our data is separated into train and
testing data using the trend test split
Technique we must first separate our
data into features X and label y divided
into X strain X text y train and Y test
the data frame is the model is trained
and fitted using extend and white train
sets okay then this is entry
a supervised machine learning algorithm
called decision tree uses a set of
principles to make judgments much like
how people do okay move forward let's
import some more libraries
so here I will write import
Rd
then import
ltk
than from
ltk Dot
I will add here stammer
equals to nltk
Dot
mobile
yeah
in English
that form nltk
purpose
upwards
okay then we'll write import
string
and I will assign stop word
equals to set
up words
and
English
yeah
okay nltk
okay
the function in the module allow you to
determine whether a given text fails a
given regular expression which is known
as a regular expression or re or if a
regular expression matches a particular
string which comes down to the same
thing
nltk the nltk toolkit was created for
python users to deal with NLP it offers
us numerous test data as data set and
different text processing libraries
using an ltk a range of activities can
be carried out including tokenizing and
visualizing parse trees
snowball stamen the stemming algorithm
also refers to as Porter 2 is timing
algorithm
is an improved version of potent stammer
because some of its shortcomings have
been addressed
okay so stopward a starboard is
frequently used um that a search engine
has been considered
both while indexing items for searching
and when retrieving them as a result of
search query
then import the string it is used to
determine whether or not substring is
part of the main string it gives back a
pointer to the first instance of S2 in
S1 I hope you guys understand clear
okay if you have any queries any
question regarding this please comment
down below
so after importing libraries let's
import our data set so I will write here
TF
equals to
PD Dot
data set name Twitter
data
okay
so
print
so this is the Twitter data set you can
download it from the description box
below and if you want to see the last
five rows instead of
top five rows you can use tail instead
of head okay
moving forward I will add a new column
to this data set as labels which will
contain the values as headspace detected
offensive language detected or no hate
no offensive language detected
okay
for that I have to write here
DF
equals to DF
map
is
which
detect
third one is
okay
the column so here I will add DF Dot
add
let's see
we have added labels
okay offensive logins
moving forward now I will only select
the tweet and the label column for the
rest of the task obtaining a hate speech
detection model okay so here I will
write DF equals to d f
after that tweet
I guess yeah you can see here
tweet
comma
labels
right here DF dot hat
here you can see
it okay so moving now I will create a
function to clean the text in the Tweet
column like this
that at the rate and this exclamation
this type of words
so here I will add
BF clean
next
red text
equals to
HDR
x equals to
3 Dot substring
Dash this Dot
uh
question mark
then
come on
and I will write here text equals to
re Dot substring
https
plus then
w w
it's Plus
get comma
text
okay here I will write text
to re Dot
subscribe
dot start
us
come on
here then let me
so here I will add text equals to
re Dot substring
foreign
dot punctuation
here again text equals to
read Dot substring
then
for the next line
Obama
no d
w
ow
[Music]
next equals to
click on stop
that's a question
and I will add DF then column in tweet
so DF
we have to type print
so everything will be clean like this
let me run it
okay so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code so please
comment down below so everything is
sorted now everything is clean
okay so moving forward now let's split
the data set into training and test set
and train a machine learning model for
the task of head speech
okay so here I will add x equals to
P dot array
then DF
foreign
then DF
found
equalizer
here I will add x equals to
CV dot fit
or transform
X
okay
here I will write X underscore train
let's go test
again
okay and that's cool test
X form of Y comma
size
questions
will be
25 equals to
BC
I will write classifier Dot
fit
okay let me run it
okay d
f
the season 3 classifier sorry my bad
the input contains an n
okay there is one empty
it's working
so
moving forward now let's test this
machine learning model to see if it is
detecting say it is speech or not okay
so here I will write test
underscore
yeah
okay
so I will give one sentence here like
I
and DF equals to
transform
test underscore data
cool
today
then here I like print
classifier
as you can see
at speed is detected because I will kill
you there is something hate on that
so let me write another sentence here
like
you
we done it
so here you can see no hate and
offensive speech you are awesome
so
private another one
like you
okay press enter
so here you can see it is not hit speed
but offensive language
okay
I hope you guys must have already
understand how you can return hate
speech using machine learning if you
have any queries you can ask in the
comment section below our team will
respond as soon as possible
don't forget to check the course link
from the description box below and don't
forget to download the data set from the
description box and if you want to this
full code just comment for the same
thank you so much for being here if you
enjoyed this video please subscribe to
our YouTube channel and press that Bell
icon to never miss any update from
Simply love and give like to this video
thank you and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here